thank you
[Music]
welcome back to an episode of the
careful boys today we have Colleen with
us
here's an interesting question that I
wonder if anybody would know how to
navigate this but I do if you're if
you're attracted to someone over social
media and you'd like to ask them out how
do you achieve that without being creepy
oh that was tough I feel like that's
been most of how I date
Joe's a master then okay how'd you do it
without being creepy well either even if
I meet them briefly in real life most of
the chatting is on social media but
let's say like then how do you cold chat
someone that you like I say you've never
even talked to them you just see their
account and they're hot I want to know
me pursuing them and they're not
pursuing me that doesn't even relate to
anyone I first he's on another Universe
no no no
before YouTube okay believe it or not
I dated okay I had girlfriends okay
Ripley okay believe it or not
this was okay there was Myspace there
was and way before that there was find
the picks oh yeah that's what I was on
that remember find a pics because you
could just rate whatever and then you
can like get their email or I forgot
exactly how it went down but you can
chat with the person on Final you could
get their aim or whatever right still
not relatable to a lot of people okay
Facebook we're moving further away
Facebook yeah
another tactic
thing like how do you cold chat someone
that is not talking to you at all
they're just a person on a page and you
want to reach out that's the opener
what's the hey believe it or not believe
it or not
okay on Instagram yeah this is this is
no particular specific person but I
think the easiest way is comment
but don't be a [__] fan don't be a
[__] weirdo be authentic so find like
a picture okay right so if it's a post
of a girl cooking what would you say
damn look at that ass
no like not that you could you could
comment right you could like their
pictures
no but what I do is like
if they if they if they visit your page
and they like your photo they comment
back then you know it's game on and then
you DM them whatever so that's your like
Olive Branch yeah if they interact then
there's a there's a there's there's an
open door for you those are the rules of
social media right you're saying though
like what's
uh or like dming you know you could
sometimes directly DM yeah but like what
is the deal
I know all the platforms
what's the actual words okay I'm trying
to start from Basics yeah that people
don't even know what to do okay yeah
you're right you're right okay so like
some guys or some guys all right so guys
are just going
[Music]
um
some guys they don't even know they
don't even know proper and
like
some guys they don't even know like all
right they'll be
my stupid younger self right
yeah
put it this way right
um like let's say you're on a plane and
there's a pretty girl walking by okay if
she looks at you and you guys lock eyes
and you give each other a quick smile my
younger self would be like what a
friendly person my older self would be
like oh what's up and then I might say
something because I feel like oh she she
opened up a little bit Yeah okay versus
back then would be like oh she's so
friendly okay minding my own business
she was pretty though damn I I wonder if
she'll ever date me versus now I'm like
oh okay that was a she recognized and
there's a possibility we could have a
conversation it might be that she's
friendly or it might be that uh she
found me attractive so there's a
different mentality right so see what
that means same with Instagram
it doesn't always mean that but I mean
like some people they're they're like
this some people they're like this
because they don't want to [__] talk
to anybody and you can feel it you can
tell
same thing with Instagram right you know
they're not really open to have a
conversation or anything get the [__]
point versus oh okay this is like
somewhere something that they're
interested in maybe what I'm doing my
you know my Adventures whatever like
there's like you got to know like what's
in their head too yeah reading the room
a little bit exactly so read the room so
it's like they don't even know that so
first and foremost don't go straight to
the [__] DM and just like profess
your love to a complete stranger
that does work sometimes though yeah
well you're come on you're playing with
a different deck over there no no
relatable guys all right first of all
off the market just speaking
hypotheticals here all right totally
worthy anyways Vietnamese Harry Styles
yeah oh that's a good one he's not
um you know uh I got one one of the
homies in Kansas uh I'm not gonna put
his name on blast Charles
um Charlie but man this guy the way this
guy [__] just slides into DS and just
throws them out there and and maybe it's
a numbers game I don't [__] know how
many no's go by and how many how many
times it doesn't work do you know what
he says
your copies and paste all day long I
feel like it's like very very direct
it's not like hey let's go on a date
it's always like hey you have a nice
smile
but it's also very is that in the
comments or is that in the DM DM or
something like so it's like it's very uh
forward but it's not that forward it's
like it's still in a safe place I guess
but the way this guy throws this kind of
stuff out
and it works I'm always I'm honestly
like very impressed because not because
he I don't think he deserves it but
because I'm like wow that it works often
and suddenly it's like oh yeah I'm going
on a date with this person but you never
did it uh dude honestly I was in the
[__] Myspace area you know what I'm
saying find a pic no I've been a
long-term relation for a long time I
don't feel like I got a chance to use
social media like that oh you know what
I'm saying but like that's why when I
see it I'm very impressed because I
didn't know how that [__] worked I was I
was in the like where I think it doesn't
matter if it's social media it's just if
you know how to talk or not yeah like
everything is just like talking to
someone at the bar or in person or at an
airport or restaurant is the exact same
thing and someone like like uh Charles I
think if you know how to put like your
intention forward but you're so secure
with yourself the other person feels it
yeah if you're like do you want to go on
a date with me they're like I'll be like
of course I really like to smile she put
it you put it out there and then you're
fine are you a dentist
you know regardless you know why your
question so hard I don't use pickup
lines I don't go in with the intention
of immediately wanting to [__] so like
mentality that I have is I just have a
genuine interest in people and if this
is an interesting looking life that they
have on Instagram then I'll comment on
it but then if she's just
then I guess like the younger me would
just care if she was pretty but now
there's so many pretty girls so when I
was single like it was like what's the
bars what what's beyond that like you
better be fun like you could be pretty
as hell but you might just you better be
fun
beautiful but you better be fun
that's actually kind of bad that's kind
of fire and that's not really a neck
it's actually a pretty funny thing
because it puts a ball back at her Court
her Court to respond to it yeah instead
of just you're pretty fine you better be
fun
okay I say the difference is the younger
the younger self the younger self would
be asking for the younger self would be
asking for approval
so that's the different mentality and
approach the younger self is look is
auditioning and looking for approval the
older one is just like let's just talk
who are you
and then do We Vibe and oh yeah we don't
okay anyone's looking to not waste time
exactly and then the younger ones just
looking for something pretty different
you don't even know what you want uh so
I think the DMS change and the
conversation changes depending on what
age you are based on what you get in
your inboxes what's an example of
somebody who could talk to you that you
had never even seen this guy before that
you were like actually interested a
little bit
um to continue it helps because
we have mutual friends so you know in
like Instagram sounds like followed by
z
um the conversations topic started off
of that person and not between us the
bridge yes okay so that I think that
helps just to like have a conversation
or like a topic to talk about that isn't
so geared towards my interest in you or
how fun you are that's I think the best
Yo that is such a mall opener back in
the day yeah do you know Stacy
you look so familiar
so if you want to cold call someone on
the DMS and you don't have mutual
friends you got to be like oh my God
like you look so familiar
no no it does type so familiar so
familiar like um you hang around blank
spot right and then just try it out and
see what happens that's happened a few
times and it works right all the time
just
because it's literally like I I just
look at him like where are you gonna go
from here like keep building the
narrative it's the same for everything
like everything like whether you're
hiring someone making a friend
networking and trying to find a
significant other you just want to meet
someone that's interesting right so it's
the same one or like wait
Elon Elon Musk it is me are you looking
for an appointment like that's so weird
right so that and and the girlfriend
realm is the same thing like wait Stacy
hey it's me Stacy yeah they just want to
put out something you have to put out
something that's interesting that makes
the other person go okay this guy is
interesting enough for me to I already
have like my friends that I want to let
someone new into my life and even start
something new yeah right or you you cold
call somebody and you text somebody you
go what do you bring to the table and
just see just see what's up that's
[__] hilarious what can you bring to
me I think that's a big key thing is
like finding a common interest or
something in common yeah you can at
least tap on because that happened to me
with uh with a girl that I dated for a
little bit
um I didn't know who she was like we had
no mutuals no nothing but we were
following the same car pages on IG and
like I would see her comments sometimes
I just remember her because oh what's a
pretty girl like that doing in these
same car Pages come to find out we have
the same car like we had the same like
79 and then uh and then we just started
I think I talked to her and I was like
what what are you doing when the car
like that in her area because she lived
in like a snowy part of Canada I was
like how do you even drive that and then
we just would talk about that first like
wait let me masturbate before I continue
this conversation yeah and it wasn't
like I never I never like straight up
said like oh you're hot it was like
months and months went by of us talking
about other [__] yeah until like that's
how it goes now yeah and then she was
the first person to initiate some form
of like hey that was a little flirt why
did you say that yeah I'm like because
she's probably like you [__] take too
long man yeah [__] me already and then I
was like why are you trying to ruin our
friendship for
it's like that and then you pull that
same [__] and it's like okay but then
again like some dudes some dudes were
like super eager like can't really do
that but also you may not even be
genuinely interested in the same thing
she is so then that's kind of a yeah I
think there's a different approach if
you're out there trying to bang a lot
versus if you're trying to have
relationships like the whole
conversation is completely different
exactly and they can sense it
I think it's so apparent when dudes are
just trying to [__]
yeah but guys are so stupid they think
they're smooth and they say stupid
things well I know it works both ways
like I've seen I've seen homies in the
uh I've seen homies in like the dating
app space like a like a Tinder right and
you know when somebody's on the market
like sometimes they're out there to date
and like look for Love sometimes they're
just trying to have fun and like that
[__] just happens like people be in the
in the DMS right and it'll just be like
oh you're just looking for some fun and
people will just like be out that it's
the same thing as literally just like
hey I'm just trying to [__] real quick
that's it one time transaction don't
make it weird and that's just common you
know what I mean so I just feel like the
culture of sliding into people's games
even by way of things like dating app
because if you're already on the market
you're already looking for things like
this you're probably yeah you're
familiar with it and I think that there
is an actual culture to it I know a
bunch of dudes that actually get slid
into the dams by chicks now that I never
thought would have ever happened were
like chicks making the first move he's
talking about me yeah
that probably helps if they have like
some sort of foundation as far as their
profile like yeah interactive value like
like 30 million followers
[Laughter]
yeah like that's that's when that's
happening but if you are just like a
regular you know human being that just
happens on social media platforms I
think context is always helpful too
right
um outside of just like the uh the the
thing in common or the bridge it's like
even this [__] time stamps on when
your messages go through you know what I
mean there's a difference between
texting somebody at like two in the
morning versus like in the middle of the
day you know what I mean the time zones
are replying every five seconds yeah or
replying every five six or when it says
like just seeing your messages but like
you don't respond for like two days you
know what I mean it happened to me so I
sold something on OfferUp I sold like an
Apple Watch and so the guy of Isaac
comes he buys it cool
like maybe like a five second exchange
right 2 am he sends me a message on
offer I can't stop thinking about you
man through his Apple watch though
you're hot you're testing the Apple
watch for his girlfriend for her
birthday oh he messages me
yeah he messages me on offer up at like
2 A.M just like you're the most
beautiful woman I've ever seen I'm like
what you should have just sought it out
a little who knows where that would have
gone
I gave him a deal too because he's like
I'm buying it for my girl I'm like I
don't even know want to even have a girl
too I hope you don't have a girl because
that's so [__] up he was gonna re-gift
it to you he was gonna make you his girl
cheers
[Laughter]
if he did that as a joke yeah I think
that would be funny but if it was
serious I'd be like
when you got that message and you were
like oh what a disgusting guy hold on
you're like block you're like still got
it
part of you that was like damn I'm good
like holy
that's right before I go to bed soon I'm
like oh my God I slept extra well that
night stopping in your eyes you're like
I am that [__]
a lot of girls on offer which sucks
because they find out where you live bro
if you're a girl you can't stop things
on offer you gotta you gotta meet up at
a gas station give it to me yeah I don't
even like selling [__] on offering other
people sell [__] on OfferUp cause I'm
too lazy
dude that sucks man other people know
where I live but that's a good place to
pick up women though
yeah
um I'm gonna start shopping
it's a good place to re-gift
guys are always searching though that's
such a funny thing so funny good sketch
dude
that's kind of brilliant yeah you see
like an attractive person selling an
item you're like yeah I'm gonna go buy
this but just give it back to you
and then like take her out on a date
maybe something into your Apple watch
this is so funny and random
weird things have happened on offer up
you know
it's like what Craigslist it used to be
yeah brain is going no I'm just like
laughing at the idea of doing that to
everybody like if you buy flowers on the
roadside and you just give it back to
that woman I got these for you as a
seller that's great thank you so much
because now she could sell it back again
let's keep doing this exchange
selling it to you over and over that's
like those bar girls at the lounge
they're like you want to buy me a drink
and it's like come on dude yeah what's
the equivalent to women doing that to
men when women are very clear and you
can smell it they're just trying to use
you for your table and or like for the
alcohol that is all it's trashy to me
but if you're like hella fine and I'm
like lonely then like it's worth it
I don't know if women even do that a lot
because that doesn't happen to me very
much where like a girl DMS me and it's
just like being straight up how many
guys doing you though you're [__]
fine dude gay dudes whoa whoa guys
I've had homies on Tinder where they're
like talking to a girl and then it's
like going well and then they'll be like
all right we'll hang out I'll see you
Thursday night at this place I can't
wait to meet you cuckoo cool cool and
then the message of the next day is like
hey uh I need to get a haircut and and
my haircut's 300 could you send me that
dude like that's that's that's really a
guy running that account it could be it
could be but if it happens pretty
frequently maybe to my buddy yeah yeah
yeah that's the thing it's like I think
it's the cold the cold talk is probably
the most challenging for a lot of people
who are like lonely yeah because if
you're it's the hardest for anything
even if you've ever done like a
telemarket or sales job it's just hard
oh you know what if if you're lonely I
think the first step before you start
looking for love or something is just
get friends yo
community
one of me for being basic that's what I
was trying to tell people is there's
steps to this [__] yeah you gotta like
their picture before you [__] message
them straight up and say I wanna [__] no
I don't think that's a good idea right
like you can't yeah you're not gonna
climb Mount Everest and the first time
you want to go hiking right well you
know even to to Bart's like cold calling
analogy that's like a good point because
cold calling anything is difficult until
that's your only job yeah and you do it
like 80 times you get desensitized to
something and you get better at
something dude yeah just look at Indian
dudes on Instagram so you're not
thinking about your failure you're just
thinking about finding the success when
I was a waiter right like my I used to
hate I used to hate it no is that funny
no I used to hate going up to tables I
used to hate like making the intro like
oh [__] like hi guys I'm Nick I'll be
your server a little bit of Johnny
Rockets you know
server came over and didn't
it like uh like I would I was pretty
social like I had no problem talking to
people but like I'd always hate to be
like oh [__] but then the more you do it
over and over again it's like not a big
thing probably because it feels fake
from a conversation where it's again
like you have Rapport or yeah
when are you doing enough you find your
voice yes and then you feel comfortable
just talking to people about anything
and anyone like could be a girl or a guy
or whatever now there was this one
waiter and he would always do this he'd
pull up and he'd be like he'd pull up a
chair to the table and he goes hey guys
uh what can I get for you hey I'm Toby
I'll be uh I'll be ready your your your
table today uh what can I get and you
make stupid things hey guys I'm Nick I'm
Toby's A co-worker I don't need any uh
shakes
so Toby had to run out for a moment
[Laughter]
I need somebody to work with Toby I'd be
like this [__] guy dude I was like
nobody likes that I'll be talking yeah
everyone's like okay but it's also
because it's not natural yeah because if
people are really themselves people feel
it and they'll actually like Toby some
some guys could pull it up
and they're like all right dude you just
want tips bro get the [__] out of here
foreign
[Music]